have any recommendations on level of vitamin D in the blood that you would recommend for your patients,
just kind of talked about that. I am mainly dealing with skin cancer. A few months ago,
my tested level was 24, which I understand is inefficient. I get plenty of sunshine daily,
living in Mexico, and pretty much never supplement for vitamin D, I think. But in spite of the
careful sun, intake seems, the level is not efficient. Although I rarely get sick with cold
subs, et cetera, if the supplement is recommended, what dose would you suggest to start?
So vitamin D levels of 24, regardless of whether you have cancer or not, is way too low.
So why would somebody have low vitamin D levels? Maybe start with that question.
Person would have low vitamin D levels. Maybe they have a VDR, that's the receptor,
for vitamin D. Maybe they have a VDR gene defect, so that you could have specific vitamin D
genes, and you have defects of those genes, so you don't produce as much vitamin D, you don't
absorb as much vitamin D. That's one possibility. So I've had people that are taking 10,000,
I use a vitamin D daily, and they can't get their vitamin D levels over 35 or something like that.
Well, then you look at their genes, and they have a defect of that gene, so they just have to take more.
Number two, a person can have a vitamin D deficiency, because they're on cholesterol-lowering drugs.
So 25-hydroxycholesterol in the skin is what is converted to vitamin D through the act of some
shine. So if you have a cholesterol, if you're on a cholesterol-lowering drug, it can lower that,
and you could end up with difficulty making vitamin D from some shine. Well, you could say, well,
if I have to be on this cholesterol-lowering drug, some people may have to be, that's another bad class
of drugs in my opinion. But if a person feels like they have to be on that drug, they can always
supplement with vitamin D. It doesn't affect the absorption of vitamin D. They can also have
gut issues. So if you have inflammatory gut issues, which might not even have symptoms of,
that can affect the absorption of vitamin D consumed. So probably some other thoughts of why a person
would have low vitamin D levels. But then what do you do about it? So you have to, you're going
to have to take vitamin D. So if your vitamin D is 24, if you live in Mexico, if you get plenty of
sun, you're falling to one of those categories. And you're going to have to take vitamin D. I would
start with, you know, always do something and then you re-measure it, right? I would start with
5,000. I use a vitamin D per day, maybe even 10,000. Vitamin D is stored. It's a fat cellular vitamin,
so I don't necessarily need to take it daily. Some people take 50,000. I use a week. But I think it's
better to take things daily as far as helping with absorption goals. So maybe 5,000. I use a week.
It depends on the person's weight. And then re-measure. Re-measure your vitamin D levels and see if
that's enough. That's adequate for you. Again, like I think I said last week or the week before,
when you do blood work and then you do some intervention, you want to re-measure to see if your intervention
worked, right? See that over and over again where that doesn't happen. Well, I don't think that's
good. Doctorate, so.